so the CEO of Coca-Cola made 50 million
bucks last year a lot of money right
okay that's earned income government's
going to take half of it Warren Buffett
invest in Coca-Cola he was paid 508
million come on last year that's passive
income that's a dividend yes you know
how many people on the internet want to
be the boss a lot dude the boss don't
make any money the investor does don't
be the boss don't be the CEO be the
investor yeah just invest and what is
warranty Warren is how I got in real
estate I started buying real estate
because I studied the old man the old
man's only invested in stocks right I'm
like I'm not gonna do stocks because I
don't like them but what I wanted to
learn Warren Buffett what was he doing
he did not buy the cheapest company he
didn't buy it low and sell High what was
he doing he bought air value at a fair
price he bought the best quality at a
fair price he wasn't looking for the day
a stock went down to one dollar he's
never done that he invests in companies
that all cash leaders in their space uh
Coca-Cola Apple computer he didn't buy
Apple computer for years until he
understood that Apple computer was a
cash flow company because of iTunes
everything he buys is really real estate